what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel so
crazy funny story so on my tic toc
account
i am doing rejection therapy and
basically that means every day you seek
out rejection
you ask to do something kind of off the
wall just see if you can get it
and i decided to call the president of
the milwaukee bucks and
ask to interview him and he actually
said yes so just goes to show you you
never know what someone is going to say
yes to
and now you guys are about to watch the
interview from that
yeah i'm excited to have you thank you
for coming on well i think like we like
your
persistence like you're a little bit
relentless and kind of fun so we were
all about it
what prompted you to take an interview
with a stranger
well we vetted you number one so not
that much of a stranger
i think you're fun you've got an
interesting following and uh
we liked the way you went about it so on
my channel it's a lot of young men and
there a lot of them are looking to like
be in a position
that you're in i really wanted to talk
more about your journey to like getting
here
yeah i think the answer to the first
question is how do you do it with with a
hell of a lot of help
okay and you know great like mentors and
and great support
in in like a big way and of course
getting like experience
you know and exposure and part of that
is what you experience is how do you get
exposed to new people and
you're relentless and kind of work your
butt off
and go really hard and the other part
about that is just
being really specific on kind of what
direction you want to go it might pivot
and change
but hey i want to learn about sales i
want to learn about marketing i want to
learn about operations especially as
you're kind of
growing up like professionally like
through that to get to a place where you
can be exposed to enough disciplines
where you say hey i want to run an
organization i get this
because you've got to have the vision to
say like oh this is something i can do
and i'd love to
work my way towards that so what's the
road map to get there
yeah so i actually had a question about
your roadmap because it was i was
looking at your linkedin profile
so you worked at six flags which
is a fire amusement park um
and then you like work on jets sure and
then you ended up at the buck so could
you tell me a little a little more about
that
yeah so so kind of always in sales and
marketing to start kind of on the
revenue side of businesses six flags the
parks was the most fun at the time i
could ever imagine great brand
kind of all the warner brothers and
looney tunes and kind of destination
theme parks really learned like the
media business on
on buying advertising on branding
on selling in a big way and then kind of
from there went to madison square garden
where i became chief marketing officer
of of the knicks
and uh the garden same type of thing
what's the call to action
how do you fill the arena how do you
build the brand how do you drive revenue
and sponsorships
uh and then kind of had an opportunity
in private aviation
to go to a startup called marquis jet
which i stayed at you know for about a
decade and built it up into
you know about a billion dollar company
until was acquired by berkshire hathaway
and uh net jets
and stayed there for a little while and
that too was all about kind of it was a
luxury product like building marketplace
and really understanding
selling 101 and driving revenue and
that's where i got my operational
experience of how to manage people how
to manage budgets how to think of like a
business in a bigger sense
um to get it and you know the story of
how i found the box is is kind of
it has everything to do with my past but
it's really i have an identical twin
brother who runs a school a private
school in new york city
that two of our owners kids went to and
during one of their parents conferences
the the parent mentioned that he was
looking to buy a professional team and
my brother mentioned like hey you should
talk to my brother he kind of gets his
business
like in a good way and he's not one of
your quantitative dorks
to to go look at it and uh
and mark lazary grabbed me to you know
about a decade ago to start looking at
teams when he looked at teams and that's
kind of how i got attached to
this opportunity about seven years ago
we came to milwaukee
and actually had like the opportunity to
buy the team so it was actually part
like right place right
time which it always is you know i
always tell people
like when i talk at classes and stuff
like i've been really lucky collecting
people
like how do you stay attached to any
network it's who you know
it really is and kind of what the
opportunities are because it's timing
but it's also like how do you build your
network and
timing is about knowing where the
opportunities are
wow that's so so your brother like just
happened to know a guy that was like
casually buying a sports team
yeah and i casually happen to have the
experience yeah like
this person trusted my identification
brother like with his children's
education life and all
and kind of intrinsically kind of said
like oh i'd like to meet him and
met him and that's how that started so i
actually i saw an interview where you
said that your greatest strength
or one of your greatest strengths is
that you're delusional that you feel
like you can get anything that
could do or like you can accomplish
anything
so i'll tell you a great story that has
to do with you i mean one of my favorite
games like when i was a young
sales person was like to get anybody on
the phone i could imagine so why
couldn't i get a ceo on the phone
to talk about buying a suite you know at
madison square garden or
sponsorship or something like that so i
loved how you were like
hey we're going to call we're going to
get access to and like call these
like c-level folks to do and i think
unless you think that way
it's never going to happen and you know
kind of in a microcosm here in milwaukee
like
you know if you told you know your
average citizen of milwaukee like we're
gonna
we're gonna come and build a new arena
build a district have a championship
caliber team
dude you know they'd say like you're
crazy like what are you talking about
but
you have to have kind of the goal and
the vision you know
before you go for it so when you got on
the phone with those people what would
you
say because i worked in sales for a
little bit
and i would get hung up on a lot i'm not
gonna lie to you
so like what did you do to like i don't
know in like 30 seconds or less
pitch yourself yeah it's so funny so you
really think about that because it's the
elevator pitch
like in two seconds so you know very
quickly like hey i'm so happy to get you
on the phone i know you've got
10 seconds so like i want to give the
opportunity of like
what we're selling and this is who i've
been happy to follow up with you
having to follow up with anything else
but like i know you're the decision
maker
and kind of powered up and just get
really excited to kind of connect with
that direct person
what press that like what was um if you
got someone on the phone how often did
were you able to set a meeting
very low really very low i would say you
know like
you know i think those are low numbers
but if you call enough people it turns
into hundreds of meetings you know so
it's kind of that you know when you're
when you're learning about
networking and selling you know
everybody's like fill the funnel you
know get hundreds of stuff
so you know over time you know if you're
doing you know if you're doing 100
meetings a year
and five years and you've networked with
500 people it all kind of
compounds and really builds up well i
think a lot of people end up like
quitting sales because they
like they think they're bad at it they
don't have what it takes so it's
actually
encouraging to hear that even you like
have a little percentage when you've got
people on the phone
yeah you've got to have that delusional
dna like yeah you know you got to be
okay with like defeat and like
because you know you're going to win
like in the end so i i do think at least
in my brain it's kind of a competitive
like
i'm not going to let these jerks like
you know like i'm gonna get this i'm
gonna like book more revenue than you
could ever imagine i mean really a sales
is like competing you know even if it's
within yourself
like you've gotta be you've gotta love
closing you've gotta like some people
like love money you know because it
usually
you know it usually equates to like the
more the better you are at it the more
money you make so there are all these
different
carrots that you know people go after
right so one thing i wanted to talk
about was
habit what decisions did you make when
you were young in order to get to where
you are
yeah i think you know you gotta kind of
like i knew like the sales experience
would be incredible for me like the
little
cold calls closing everything i knew i
wanted to understand marketing and media
and branding you know i knew like what
the building blocks were the more i got
exposed to things so it was kind of like
when to take those steps and when to
kind of understand
in a big way and then you know i think
the other part about it is like
throughout that journey you are like the
best i always find the best people are
the most curious so you're not just
learning about
kind of your own industry you are like
insatiable about
kind of knowing as much as you can know
about everything because it helps right
you know it like helps so
how do you how do you continue to
broaden your horizons and
yeah listen some of that is reading now
it's like incredible because
you know when i was growing up like we
didn't have podcasts like we didn't have
youtube channels like we didn't
i mean the wealth of of i mean it's
almost like too much it's like a rabbit
hole you know you can get way too
like deep into it but your ability to
kind of understand the whole industry
understand people get backgrounds like
you can do it in minutes you know that
used to take hours
right and then i think you know just
self-discipline i think you know if i
was
20 years younger i would have been
diagnosed with add and kind of been a
normal but you know they didn't have
that
really so how you know in my own
personal thing i like impulsive
you know crazy how do you kind of
control all your
you know i think it's it's turned into
attention deficit advantage you know
versus disadvantage like
how do you you know take those things
and uh and i was really lucky at two
like professional parents who were like
awesome
really supportive you know kind of
infrastructure you know went to
went to you know great schools like
where i learned and had
great professional experience and and i
think
you know if i didn't have a father who
told me i couldn't quit sales you know
it kind of kept me there maybe i would
have quit sales you know which is funny
he just you know hadn't kind of done it
for two years and just said you just
have to you will learn more and of
course he was right and i tell people
here and
in sales jobs like no this is like
you're gonna learn more
even through rejection and failure than
you will ever learn at the very least
you'll learn to what you don't want to
do
but just go through like a little bit of
pain right you know and i think there's
there's probably probably not the best
advice but there's not much
people going through pain you know or
adversity
you know everybody wants you know as
time goes people wanted it
the easiest path possible and i just
don't know if there's an easy path
were there any like painful rejection
stories that you can think of where you
think back and like kind of wince a
little bit
yeah i mean i would say like rejection
and making big mistakes are kind of the
same
okay same kind of thing like whether
it's like a flubbing
you know public speaking or doing a deal
that actually
you know was not a good smart deal and
and those kind of
things i mean i think um the key to
everything is
you know how do you recover and how they
react and you know
you don't cover things up and you don't
you know if you're in a hole
you stop digging so one thing um i've
kind of noticed with like the successful
people that i've talked to
is they're very like it's not that they
don't make mistakes but they make
decisions like
quickly and they like pick a way to go
with it and like
deal with the results does that make
sense yeah i think that's
1 000 like the way i am so i think it's
like we're gonna make mistakes but
if you've got an organization that's
completely focused and geared to the
right direction you know like we're
doing things to build the business we're
doing things to
improve the customer experience all this
like your mistakes aren't going to be
that big but you've got to tactically
get things done so
let's not overthink like especially the
simple stuff
like let's make decisions and move the
needle do you feel like you were like a
natural born leader or was it something
you had to learn
i think i always aspired to like want to
be a leader i think like playing sports
like you know kind of if i was a
freshman sophomore you know by the time
i was a junior senior i wanted to be the
captain of the team and set the example
and
it's definitely i think one of those dna
things that probably is in
in your body like you know leading is
you know kind of that big responsibility
of like
how do you set the example how do you
and by the way ego wise too right like
you want to be
you want to be the person right you know
what does that what does that do so i
was always kind of motivated to be like
oh my god do i want to like i want to be
the captain team
i want to run this club i want to like
you know
to to be a bigger part as much as i
could
my dad he like owns a software company
and he's always said that like it's not
always like the people that succeed that
like work the hardest or are the
smartest people that know how to
communicate
and know how to like manage people would
you say that's true
no question i think there's some of the
most productive like smartest people
in the world that you sit there and say
like oh my god like why aren't they like
running this one part of it is like the
interpersonal like ability to
communicate and collaborate like if you
can't do it like
it's it's the biggest fault you know
back to it's all about people
communication i mean my job
like as a leader is to like clean the
plate for people to focus on
kind of growing the business so how do
you get rid of all the little crap
of of toxic people of political
you know politics and business of people
being upset over little things of
people not getting promoted getting
promoted like how do you
kind of think about that and really kind
of clean that plate make everything very
transparent
and have everybody kind of have no
excuse other than to focus on how do we
grow the business
right no and it's um it's pretty cool
because you can see like as soon as you
like took over you guys like took off
we just had the greatest opportunity
because this was kind of like a
different place like it was a real
distressed business
you know this was like you know and by
the way like an incredible
there are only 30 nba teams it's a
global sport it grows like you can
imagine so
such an opportunity for a small market
to have like one of these like
franchises in such a big way and at the
time
the bucks were you know last in almost
every metric that can exist in the nba
so you know you kind of say oh my god
this is awful i say like oh my god this
is unbelievable like
there's no other way you can do but
succeed like you can
you know like going from zero to one is
not like
you know too difficult like so so i just
got so excited i was like oh my god this
is going to be
like a real opportunity to just flip the
world on a test
i wanted to say congrats on making it to
the finals
that's amazing well the eastern
conference files this is and it's such a
great
like launch pad because like as as fewer
teams are in the playoffs
like the global focus becomes those
cities those teams is everything so we
have this
platform now that like you just can't
imagine you have where the focus of
you know not only the nba fans but
really the global fans are like
going to be in milwaukee wisconsin yeah
the bucks really put milwaukee on the
map
like yeah i think there's like a kind of
there's a there's a nice rejuvenation
like in the city you know like this was
like one of the greatest cities you know
kind of like by industry by population
by everything and it's so ripe to kind
of be converted i mean it's kind of our
owner's vision was like
how do we build a district you know like
within the city to
because we thought that'd be
unbelievable opportunity for growth
right oh tell me about
the game tonight oh it's
it's you know really one big step you
know to the semi-finals of like
how do we get it's kind of the focus of
national tv you know on
on one sport and uh it's
nerve-racking exciting you know kind of
inspirational we think it's a
springboard you know to get to the nba
finals and
uh worked hard through like a like a
semi-long journey to get there so
it's great what do you think is what do
you think the biggest
strength is as a team and what do you
think is going to be the biggest
challenge for the game tonight
yeah so i think the biggest strength is
is just literally kind of
our culture our teamwork our leadership
whether it's giannis whether it's jew
whether it's coach bud
it's kind of like you know it's a solid
you know
veteran-esque team that's kind of been
through adversity in the last round were
down a couple games
and came back so i think kind of the and
kind of the community culture of
of really kind of circling the wagons
and and fighting together in such a big
way and i think you know it's
challenging these are like
you know the nba playoffs where you know
every game
you know is competitive and then and
fierce so
you know anything can happen and then
you know the kind of variables of health
you know you want everybody to stay
you know healthy because you know injury
is you know makes a big difference
oh so one i actually had some of my
viewers submit questions so these are
going to be a little random sure
these are just the ones that they
submitted
what do you think is more important
championships or revenue
oh that's a great question so i'll say
championships because
championships drive more revenue like in
a big way but i think
we're we're geared i mean on parallel
paths like we want to win a championship
off the on the court and we want to win
a championship off the court which is
like managing like a growth business
like in a big way so that's the way we
look at it and like we always say
kind of like our general manager john
horse and i are always like oh no we
our priorities to win a championship
like make no doubts about it and then
corresponding our our goals as a
business is to
be an aggressive growth business
for the next couple of years are you
one of the one of my viewers was asking
if you're nervous because you guys have
spent a lot of money
in the last couple years and you've
given up some draft picks i think any
nerves are kind of subsided by the fact
that we've
we've kind of secured like a very strong
team for a long time so when you're
managing
kind of an enterprise like a pro sports
team and you've got yana signed for five
years and chris signed for three years
and drew signed for three years
you've got like you know because this is
a sport of like humans you know and and
kind of
a competitive play you've kind of like
for the
the opportunity of really it never
happens for us to have like a road map
of
the highly competitive team and all-star
caliber players
way out ways like any nerves like we
have
okay do you believe college was critical
to your success do you think
people need it in 2021
different people different needs like do
i think people should be hired on the
base of whether they went to college
probably not but for me it was really
important
kind of like a finishing school and like
i i needed kind of the exposure
academically and and uh intellectually
so like i thought it's really important
for me
but i mean you know in this job
literally manage thousands of people and
i think all people are different
and some of our smartest people and and
most productive have
never gone to college and you know so i
think the world is kind of exposed now
to
like totally different strokes for
different folks and how do you create
diverse environments not just
like in gender and race and everything
but educational background so i think
there's
definitely opportunity uh what percent
of your success would you say was luck
um hard work and or luck versus heart
work well i think you're like prepared
to be honest
such talent sorry a lot of hard work and
talent
least talent okay um and i think you
like
you you prepare to be lucky so like
again
like relentless hard work like being
present
like you know kind of networking you
know really
caring about results that all leads to
you know
having the opportunity to make and yes
you have to have the talent so
as you're going through all these stages
how to absorb
right and learn and become you know like
an expert at everything you're doing
right well because it wouldn't have
mattered
it wouldn't have mattered if you were in
the right place at the right time if you
weren't
talented with um your brother's friend
right you definitely wouldn't sustain it
you know you can definitely find people
who are kind of like what are you doing
in this job like how'd you get this job
and their stuff
and it might be a flash in the pen but
you kind of wouldn't sustain it over
time
eventually you're exposed to yeah you
know
yeah not being so good yeah that's
that's something i've like learned is
like you can't really
cheat it like over time people figure it
out
yeah i mean listen there's some people
like i'm sure you've met that spend a
lot of time like
masquerading and and perpetrating the
fraud like in a big way and like that
might go a little bit longer but at the
end
the results are the results and if
you're spending so much time
kind of faking it hiding that'll be even
more
you know relevant what was the biggest
learning moment of your career i don't
know if there was one
great moment i mean i can tell you that
um i was a pretty like
kind of stayed professionally
conservative person that hey i need this
job i need this job i need this job and
i was at madison square garden
and these two entrepreneurs came to me
with like the idea of marquis jet we've
got this private jet
communication we're going to be in
partnership with warren buffet and
berkshire hathaway
it seems like it's going to be great we
need you to help us like structure this
and i was like oh my god like that's
completely different
from i was going to be in big
corporations and kind of maybe
maybe more like a piece of the engine
you know to
to do it but the the decision to go to
like a really entrepreneurial startup
business and help that grow was probably
the inflection point of my whole career
to get exposed to like
a whole different world of experiences
of operation of
of challenges of failure and success so
that moment of going like from
you know madison square garden and being
big part of a big corporation to really
being part of a startup
and kind of learning everything and kind
of drinking from a fire hose and
kind of learning and building a company
was probably like one looking back like
one of the best decisions
that's really interesting because i
think a lot of people when they're early
in their career
like i know when i was looking for jobs
i had like two choices i had the startup
and like the corporate
job and so you would actually recommend
i'm assuming to young people to
take the startup role first well i
didn't say that
i i had already kind of had a baseline
of of kind of
corporate training and understanding it
wasn't my first job
my my decision at that time you know
kind of in my like
mid to late 20s was like do i take away
the comfort of
almost corporate you know kind of growth
where i thought i'd be successful
and really take the risk to to to kind
of do something where i can be a bigger
part of it
like own a piece of it kind of and grow
it in a way
like almost you know like live live it
because
you know you're part of the the entire
organization in a way and that was kind
of the risk that was really worth it
because
i learned more you know during that
period than i than i ever had
yeah i'm just curious like what you
would tell like if you
uh you you have a son right yep i think
he saw my tick tock i'm pretty sure he
definitely saw your dad
yeah both my kids were both my kids
vetted your tick tock so
i have a sophomore daughter at
northwestern and a son who just
graduated high school
okay um so when he like graduates
college and he's looking to start
working would you recommend like i'm
just curious would you recommend that he
goes corporate first or that he goes
startup
since you had like a handed bull or is
it gonna work for you
i mean that's my dream would be to work
with mike with my son when i was growing
up i wanted to work with my dad but i
don't think that that
that won't happen yeah i think that's
tough to say listen i'm a you know again
i'm a different parent and like you know
i want these guys to make their
decisions and they get the advantage of
being exposed to
a lot of different stuff my kids have
like lived this job with me they've like
they've been in the office they've like
they know the
you know the finance they know the
business of everything they've
had jobs like throughout high school um
you know i would say kind of what the
opportunity is and again i'll take it
back
to like people like if you came to me
for advice
and there was a startup you wanted to be
a part of the first thing i would ask is
like
tell me about the person who's starting
it tell me about the people around them
like
do you love them like are they smart are
they people you can work with are they
people i mean that would be
my first kind of thing because if you
went to an interview and you're kind of
like
ah like i didn't really i'd be like well
don't make it about money
like you know in this in this jump right
here like
be around people like you can learn from
and i know that sounds so cliche from an
old guy but
you want to just be so curious and
absorb like the world in those jobs
like you want to get something out of it
besides money so it sounds like you're
saying to find
the most competent like leader basically
and work for them
i think it all comes from the top and
all leadership you know i report to our
owners our owners are like an incredible
board of directors like
that comes to me and then it goes down
so like i think success breeds success
so
like if you if you see a good
organization like there's going to be
something good about the leadership
there's going to be a vibe
like around the company people
understand there's good there's a
baseline of good communication
so you know and like people know that
people know what
like a good culture is people there is a
feel like
yeah by the way i tell like i tell my
kids all the time like oh it doesn't
feel right it doesn't smell right it
doesn't taste right
probably not right like yeah you're
smart like
go a different way oh did you feel like
you had to give up a lot to get where
you're at
definitely um could you talk more about
that yeah i think it's
risk reward it's sacrifice and i i think
like when you work hard and you want
success there are definitely decisions
you have to make and like
what is time you know when you talk
about the value of time which is the
most valuable thing
like you know when you're traveling you
know for business when you're not home
when you're
not with your kids you know when you're
not with your wife like things that
really matter like what is that balance
and that sacrifice like to get done so i
think i think
you know with great opportunity there's
always going to be great sacrifice and
you've got to figure
like there's at least i believe there's
you don't get something for nothing
you know like that's like true and and
you know if you don't have great
sacrifices on on certain sides like
you know the benefits will be reduced
that's actually something
because my dad he owns like a fairly big
software company
and i always say that i don't think most
people would want to be as successful as
he is because they don't know like
he worked like 80 hours a week my whole
life you know like he missed a lot of
stuff
and a lot of people like don't
understand like there's a cost to
everything
you don't have to answer this um someone
wanted me to ask you
if you have a favorite player
and a least favorite player uh
i don't have like a favorite player but
i always
i always uh i always laugh that when
chris middleton plays well he's my
favorite player and when chris
doesn't play well he's not my favorite
player
so he's i get the biggest kick out of
him but uh
no i'm like i'm i love i i love the
bobby portises of the world
as like people i have so much fun with
like we've got such a good group of guys
that it's almost like you know in
leadership like you you desperately
don't play favorites you know because
it's so exposed like
you know if you do so that's another
thing you learn in like a big way
because human nature it's hard not to
you know because you assimilate to
people
right you know like you automatically
click with some people you don't click
with other people you do but you got to
be
very balanced you know especially when
you're building a team culture
and everything that favoritism isn't a
big thing but i always like
have fun with it that's um
i like that you said that because i
always think like
people will always say like things are
unfair and like people like
my boss or whoever has favorites but i
always think like you have favorites
every single person in the world like i
mean it's all people it's all human
right
it's like who do you click with who has
a sense of humor who's sarcastic who's
like you know
who works hard like yeah it's all
different so but part of things of
managing
people and projects and business is like
you've got to balance that
like because that's toxic right i mean
all you have to be is the non-favored
one
and you're miserable do you think that
you guys are going to get a championship
ring this year definitely no doubt no
doubt